très bien mes chers collègues nous
allons pouvoir débuter
l'audition alors nous entendons ce matin
application du 5e alinéa de l'article 13
de la Constitution madame Christelle
Ratinier corboneil candidate proposé par
le prés de la République à la direction
générale de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé cette audition sera suivi d'un
vote sur cette candidature pour lequel
vous le savez aucune délégation ne sera
admise je vous précise que cette
audition fait l'ET l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et sera
consultable en vidéo à la demande
conformément au principe de publicité
prévu par la loi du 23 juillet
2010 je vous rappelle que l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé est un
établissement public à caractère
administratif chargé d'évaluer de
surveiller et de contrôler les
médicaments et les produits de santé
elle délivre notamment les autorisations
de mise sur le marché des produits de
santé réalise des inspections et peut le
cas échéant prendre des mesures allant
jusqu'au retrait d'un produit du marché
le directeur général est nommé pour une
durée de 3 ans son mandat est
renouvelable madame ratin corbonil je
vous propose de débuter cette audition
par un propos liminaire dans lequel vous
nous exposerez votre parcours
professionnel plus particulièrement vous
pourrez revenir sur votre action et
votre bilan à la direction générale
ainsi que développer la disons que vous
avez de votre prochain mandat à la tête
de cet
organisme ensuite en tant que rapporteur
de cette audition je vous poserai les
premières questions et nous ensuite nous
lancerons la discussion générale avec
les sénateurs qui souhaitent intervenir
voilà madame je vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord Toute mes excuses
pour ces quelques minutes de
retard c'est un honneur en effet pour
moi que d'être reçu ce jour par votre
notre commission à l'approche du
possible renouvellement de mon mandat de
directrice générale de la NSM pour une
deuxème et une dernière période de de 3
ans comme cela est prévu par la loi
cette procédure d'audition par le
Parlement présente pour moi une valeur
également hautement symbolique
puisqu'elle prend sa source dans la loi
de 2011 relative au renforcement de la
sécurité sanitaire du médicament et des
produits de santé ces principes visent à
garantir la pleine inscription de cet
établissement d'expertise qui prend
quotidiennement de très nombreuses
décisions nous y reviendrons dans son
environnement politique et social
indispensable au fonctionnement
démograique l'expertise doit pouvoir
être questionnée par les citoyens par
leur représentant et l'établissement
capable de rendre compte de manière
régulière et en tant que de besoin de
son action et de sa gestion ainsi c'est
dans un esprit de pleine responsabilité
que j'aborde cette audition à l'instar
de celle réalisée en décembre 2020
lorsque vous m'avez confié la mission de
directrice générale que j'assure depuis
3 ans je me propose dans un premier
temps de vous de rappeler très
brièvement mon parcours professionnel de
dresser rapidement un bilan des 3o
années écoulées pour l'agence et de vous
présenter le projet que je porte pour
cette institution et ses collaboratrices
et collaborateurs pour l'avenir mais au
préalable je souhaite d'une part vous
exposer les raisons qui m'ont conduitite
à solliciter le renouvellement de mon
mandat et d'autre part vous rappeler en
quelques mots introductifs les mission
et les activités de l'agence je suis
chercheur de formation en immuno et
hématologie et j'ai un parcours
professionnel uniquement dédié au
servicees public après après une
expérience en effet dans la recherche
dans la recherche clinique j'ai rejoint
j'ai découvert le monde des autorités
sanitaires et notamment le monde de
l'Agence du médicamament qui s'appelait
à l'époque lafsaps au sein de laquelle
j'ai pu exercer différentes fonctions à
la fois d'évaluation d'expertise mais
aussi d'encadrement managérial en 2010
j'ai eu la chance de rejoindre d'autres
activités des activités en cabinet donc
en donc dans le cadre du cabinet du
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de la
santé et j'ai pu être être mobilisé et
particulièrement impliqué dans
l'écriture et la la mise en œuvre du
fond d'indemnisation sur les victimes du
Médiator et la loi de 2011 qui en effet
a créé la NSM après cette expérience
j'ai rejoint l'assurance maladie où j'ai
pu appréhender l'ensemble des de la
dimension prise en charge sur les
produits de santé à la fois sur la
partie prise en charge au niveau du
comité économique des produits de santé
mais également aussi concernant la
partie négociation conventionnelle avec
les farm phacien avec les acteurs de la
biologie et aussi les acteurs du monde
des dispositifs médicaux et puis en
décembre 2016 lorsque Dominique Martin
était directeur général de la NSM je
j'ai rejoint je dis souvent ma maison
donc j'ai rejoint l'agence en effet en
tant que directrice générale adjointe à
partir de décembre 2016 auprès de
Dominique Martin et j'ai ensuite et en
effet vous m'avez confié la mission en
effet d'être directrice général depuis 3
ans donc vous le voyez c'est une une
institution une belle institution à
laquelle je suis très attachée et ce
renouvellement pour moi était en effet
logique à la fois pour l'intérêt
prononcé prononcer des missions de
service public en effet que que l'agence
exerce aux questions de sécurité
sanitaire un attachement vous l'avez vu
dans mon parcours à cette maison à ces
agents dont je salue le très haut niveau
d'expertise et la mobilisation au
quotidien sans faille pour la sécurité
sanitaire de nos concitoyens et le fait
aussi la conviction qu'une stabilité de
la gouvernance est importante notamment
pour guider et et accompagner cet
établissement public de référence dans
la dynamique notamment de notre future
cop de contrat d'objectif et de
performance sur
2024-2028 c'est donc dans cette logique
intégrée assumée que je me présente à
nouveau devant vous devant vous ce matin
cela a été dit par Monsieur le le
président rapporteur la la NSM est un
établissement public administratif il a
été créé il y a 11 ans par la loi du 29
décembre 2011 et aujourd'hui les presque
1000 collaborateurs de l'établissement
public exercent des missions qui cou
ouvre l'ensemble des produits de santé
les médicaments qu'ils soient chimi
qu'ils soi biologique qu'ils soi anciens
qu'ils soi expérimentaux curatifs ou
préventif comme les les vaccins et c'est
environ à peu près 12000 spécialités qui
existent sur notre territoire national
les centaines de milliers de dispositifs
médicaux qui vont des lunettes au
pansement mais qui passent aussi par des
dispositifs implantables les plus
sophistiqués les logiciel les appareils
de radiologie les produits sanguinabiles
les greffes et enfin dans un registre un
petit peu différent mais qui montre bien
l'ampleur du champ couvert les plantes
et
l'homéopathie l'agence appuie s'appuie
sur son expertise interne extrêmement
forte mais aussi sur des experts
externes dans un cadre déontologique
strictement défini et totalement
transparent c'est réellement l'ADN de la
NSM la déontologie le respect des règles
déontologiques est un élément cardinal
pour la garantie de la sécurité
évidemment de nos concitoyens mais
également aussi la viabilité et la
pérennité de la NSM et exerce de
multiples missions
d'autorisation de surveillance
d'inspection et de contrôle dans ses
propres laboratoires nous avons en effet
des laboratoire nous sommes un organisme
libérateur notamment de vaccins et de
médicaments dérivés du sang et nous
avons plusieurs sites un sur Saint-Denis
un sur Lyon et un sur vandarg à côté de
Montpellier l'agence dispose de pouvoir
de police sanitaire en propre lui
permettant si nécessaire de modifier de
suspendre d'interdire des activités des
productions des autorisations de comm
alisation dans un unique et seul but la
sécurité des patients qui utilisent au
quotidien les produits de santé elle
peut également prendre des sanctions
financière à l'encontre des entreprises
en cas de non respect de la
réglementation au total ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'avis de
décisions qui sont prises chaque année à
peu près 85000 décisions prises en effet
par la NSM enfin l'agence est pleinement
inscrite dans son environnement européen
elle participe de manière prépondérante
au fonctionnement de l'Agence européenne
du médicament et à la M mise en œuvre
des règlements européens sur les
dispositifs médicaux et les dispositifs
médicaux de diagnostic invitro cette
dimension européenne a pris une place
notable et considérable en matière de
produits de santé mais il est ici
essentiel de préciser un point
extrêmement important relatif à
l'activité au sein de l'Agence
européenne du médicament ce n'est pas
une structure supranationale l'Agence
européenne du médicament n'a pas de
force d'expertise c'est une structure de
coordination qui se repose sur les seuls
experts nationaux des AG sanitaire
nationale notamment de la NSM mais aussi
des 26 autres États-membres et ce sont
nos experts à toutes et tous en effet de
la NSM et aussi des 26 autres agences
qui construisent ensemble les
évaluations au niveau européen et qui
décide des mesures d'autorisation et de
renforcement de la surveillance c'est un
point en fait que je souhaitais
clarifier et qui est extrêmement
extrêmement important j'en viens au
bilan des 3 années passées pour l'agence
inscrite dans sa dernière année du COP
conclu avec le le ministère des
solidarité de la santé le 23 mai 2019
pour 5 ans donc à la fin à cette fin
d'année l'agence s'est pleinement pardon
mobilisé autour de ces quatre axes
stratégiques fortement guidés par
l'ouverture aux parties prenantes et la
transparence sur ses travaux vous le
savez l'activité de la période de ces 3
années a été marqué par la gestion de la
crise sanitaire covid avec une
mobilisation intense des moyens de la
NSM sur les priorités en effet de
gestion de crise dès mars 2020 notre
activité a été fortement impactée autant
sur nos mission de sécurité sanitaire
que sur celle liée à l'accès à
l'innovation thérapeutique quelques
exemples en effet l'accélération des
procédures d'évaluation des essais
cliniques pour le traitement de la
covid-19 nous sommes aux alentours de 45
jours de manière de manière classique
les délais réglementaires sont de 60
jours donc nous sommes déjà en
infraréglementaire mais pendant la
période covid nous avons été en capacité
avec une mobilisation exceptionnelle
d'être à 7 jours en terme d'évaluation
d'autorisation des C cliniques
évidemment sans renier sur la qualité
l'évaluation la qualité de l'expertise
et l'évaluation en effet du rapport
bénéfice risque la mise en place d'accès
précoce plus de 18000 qui ont permis en
effet l'arrivée des premiers traitements
à la fois curatifs et préventifs pour
les patients avec plus de 8 mois
d'avance sur le territoire national par
rapport aux autorisations qui ensuite
été donné au niveau européen un
dispositif de surveillance renforcé en
continu des effet indésirabl qui était
lié à l'utilisation des médicaments
curatifs dans le cadre de la covid mais
aussi lié euh à la vaccination avec des
études qui ont été menées grâce à notre
réseau national de centre régionaux de
pharmacovigilance vous le savez nous
avons un maillage territorial unique en
Europe et je dirais je crois même au
monde avec 31 centres qui sont implantés
dans les territoires au plus proche des
professionnels de santé et des patients
et la mobilisation également de notre
Groupement d'Intérêt Scientifique que
nous avons avec l'acnam donc le GIS
épiphar qui permet d'étudier en vie
réelle sur la base donc sur les bases de
données de l'assurance maladie euh
l'ensemble en effet du comportement de
soins des personnes qui sont traitées
notamment par des médicaments et donc on
a pu en permanence avoir des données et
et de manière en continu et très
réactive des données sur l'efficacité et
la sécurité en vraie vie je dirait en
vie réelle à la fois des traitements
mais aussi mais aussi des vaccins et
également une information en continu de
l'ensemble des usagers des patients des
professionnels de santé au travers de
webinaires ou de communication en effet
hebdomadaire euh qui était dédié en
effet au sujet euh de de de la crise et
puis nous avons dû veiller et garantir
la disponibilité des médicaments de
réanimation euh pour la gestion de la
crise mais aussi des autres traitements
pour pour les pathologies chroniques
malgré la mobilisation très forte des
équipes de l'agence sur la crise
l'agence a su garder le cap sur
l'ensemble de ces autres activités
puisque évidemment la crise était là
mais il y avait toutes les autres
activités qui évidemment devaient
perdurer euh dans le cadre de nos
missions quelques exemples le nouveau
règlement européen sur les dispositifs
médicaux les dispositifs médicaux de
diagnostic in vitro la réforme de
l'accès précoce donc des accès
dérogatoires avant l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché qui permettent à des
dizaines de milliers de patients de
bénéficier de traitement avant
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
avec une articulation étroite avec la
Haute Autorité de Santé le nouveau le
nouveau règlement européen sur les
essais cliniques avec une évolution
majeure puisque l'évaluation maintenant
est partagé au niveau européen comme
cela est le cas pour les autorisations
de mise sur le marché et en 2022 nous
avons plus de 800 autorisations d'essai
cliniques qui démontrre la le dynamisme
de la recherche clinique en effet en
France et nous sommes dans le trio de
tête en terme de nombre de demandes
d'autorisation d'ESS clinique en triau
de tête avec l'Allemagne et l'Espagne et
voilà chaque mois l'un de nous est prier
second ou 3è et et voilà et cela peut
évoluer en effet d'un mois d'un mois sur
l'autre également aussi une mobilisation
forte sur le sujet des pénuries
j'imagine évidemment qu'on y reviendra
avec le décret stock sur les mé
méicament d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur
qui pour à peu près la moitié de la
pharmacopé 6000 oblige les industriels à
avoir 2 mois de stock de sécurité et
pour certains d'entre eux 10 % 4 mois de
stock de sécurité c'est une mesure parmi
d'autres ce n'est pas une baguette
magique je le dis d'entrée et j'imagine
qu'on aura beaucoup d'échanges sur sur
ce sujet mais cela permet en effet de
donner du temps lorsqu'un industriel
déclare une tension de donner un petit
peu de temps pour je dirais se retourner
avec les patients avec les
professionnels de santé pour essayer en
effet de trouver des solutions par
rapport à ces déficits qui sont
évidemment extrêmement
impactants le premier semestre de
l'année 2022 pardon a également été
marqué par la présidence française de
l'Union de l'Union européenne et dans le
casadre de cet événement nous avons
organisé plus de 20 réunions de groupes
de travail et de comités européens une
mobilisation exceptionnelle avec plus de
157 heures de réunion 2000 participants
et 115 agents de la NSM investis au
départ on exantiel eu égard à la
présence encore forte du covid et
ensuite en en présentiel et lorsque nous
avons pu notamment la réunion des heads
donc de de mes homologues en effet en
mai 2022 cela faisait quasiment 2 ans et
demi que nous nous n'étions pas réuni en
présentiel et uniquement en effet
uniquement en distantiel donc vous le
voyez en cette dernière année d'exercice
du COP actuel un bilan qui souligne une
amélioration nette de la perception de
la NSM par les parties prenantes grâce
aux efforts d'intégration de l'ensemble
des acteurs dans nos instances et nos
processus de construction de décision
dans toutes nos instances dans tous nos
échanges nous avons des représentants de
professionnel de santé et des
représentants d'usagers à chaque message
à chaque
information recommandation décision de
la NSM cela passe par les fourches
codines de nos parties prenantes des
professionnels des santé et des usagers
pour s'assurer de la bonne adéquation du
message de la compréhension du message
et de l'adaptation si nécessaire en
effet du message en fonction en fonction
des cibles également une place de la
France retrouvée au niveau européen
c'est important je l'ai dit précédemment
beaucoup de choses se jouent au niveau
européen par exemple l'autorisation des
des médicaments innovants passe
uniquement au niveau centralisé par
l'Agence européenne du médicament donc
il faut être très présent être très
présent c'est au niveau des comités
scientifiques européens notamment que ce
soit le Comité européen des médicaments
les avis scientifiques également le
comité pédiatrique et nous avons la
chance d'exercer des présidences et de
vice-présidences par des représentants
français des représentants de la NSM et
pour ma part j'ai l'honneur d'avoir été
élu en juin 2022 vice-présidente du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence
européenne du médicament la France doit
influer doit encore être beaucoup plus
présente puisque c'est évidemment
indispensable et on le voit bien le le
maillon européen est un maillon
évidemment indispensable et puis une
mobilisation constante pour la sur le
sujet de la couverture des besoins
sanitaires on le voit des déc
déclarations qui sont en augmentation on
était à 3700 2022 on sera probablement
tantentera les 4000 des
déclarations qui ne sont pas forcément
des tensions effectives mais des risques
pour autant 40 % de ces déclarations
nécessitent des mesures parce qu'il
manque en effet des médicaments et donc
on voit bien en effet c'est un sujet
majeur de de préoccupation pour nos
concitoyens pour les professionnels de
santé pour voilà l'ensemble de la
société et évidemment pour pour la NSM
et voilà je suis sûr qu'on y reviendra
ultérieurement je terminerai par le
projet que je porte pour cette
institution ses collaboratrices et
collaborateurs pour l'avenir si vous
m'honorez de votre confiance renouvelé
dans mes fonctions de de directrice
générale en se fondant sur ce bilan
extrêmement riche grâce à la
mobilisation constate et sans faille des
des 1000 agents que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger il est clair que des activités
doivent être poursuivis et renforcé je
je l'ai déjà dit un investissement
majeur en matière de gestion des
pénuries est fortement attendu et pas
uniquement de la part de la NSM
développer encore davantage des modes de
communication encore plus proche du Pass
paent plus proche des professionnels de
santé même s'il y a déjà eu des
améliorations notables qui ont été
mobilisées mais s'assurer en effet que
chaque patient et bien laformation
chaque professionnel de santé également
et puis des objectifs ambitionux en
matière d'épidémiologie des produits de
santé donc notamment au travers de notre
Groupement d'Intérêt Scientifique qui
doivent être maintenus afin de renforcer
le suivi des produits des produits de
santé enve réelle c'est donc dans ce
contexte que je souhaite porter pour les
trois prochaines années un projet
ambitieux et il se doit de l'être pour
répondre aux défis actuels et au défis
évidemment à venir la question
européenne je l'ai déjà dit est
essentielle pour l'agence la prise en
charge sanitaire ne peut-être envisagé
sans évoquer l'échelon supranational il
faut que l'agence il faut que la France
soit omniprésente partout à l'Europe à
la fois sur les médicaments mais aussi
sur les dispositifs médicaux et
diagnosties invitro et prennent encore
davantage de place dans le concert
européen le projet que je propose
s'organise autour de quatre axes
stratégiques une agence garante de la
sécurité des patients dans le cas de
l'utilisation des produits de santé
évidemment avec un focus majeur et c'est
la le la première thématique sur la
gestion des pénurie l'anticipation parce
que évidemment nous souhaiterions tous
que nous ne soyons plus dans une phase
de gestion de pénurie mais bien
évidemment dans une dans une une
anticipation en corollaire aussi
renforcer le bon usage des produits de
santé nous le savons nous sommes de très
gros consommateurs de médicaments donc
très sensible aux tensions et aux
ruptures par définition donc tout cela
je dirais si je peux m'exprimer ainsi é
un tout donc permettant de garantir leur
efficacité je pense aux antibiotiques
limiter les prescriptions inutiles
diminuer les consommations des produits
de santé et le nombre d'effets
indésirables une agence agile et qui
accompagne l'innovation scientifique
l'accès des patients au traitement
innovant je pense par exemple aux
maladies rares où on le voit bien il
faut être agile sur notamment les
méthodologie les procédures notamment
d'essai cliniqu on le sait lorsqu'on a
un tout petit nombre de patients on ne
peut pas
forcément avoir le même typeal le même
type d'essès clinique donc il faut être
évidemment agile favoriser l'accès au
plus précoce et notamment au au prise en
charge également aussi former former mes
agents aux innovations et aux ruptures
technologiques l'intelligence
artificielle est là elle va être et elle
va l'être de plus en plus et donc
évidemment il faut en permanence que
nous soyons et que mes équipes soient
aussi formé à ces nouvelles technologies
lorsque nous allons en effet recevoir
des demandes d'autorisation d'ESS
cliniques où un bras sera mobilisé ou
réalisé grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle pour en effet être en
capacité d'appréhender et et d'évaluer
il faut en effet qu'il y ait aussi cette
formation là de nouveaux profils en
effet on le voit aussi sur la gestion
des données et la gestion des données en
effet de grandes de grand volume une
agence à l'écoute et au service des
citoyens être évidemment dans la
transparence c'est ce que nous faisons
déjà mais aller encore plus loin dans
l'accès à nos données euh la la
personnalisation de l'information des
publics être en écoute en effet et et
avoir les remontées les remontées de
terrain les plus proches et c'est dans
ce cadre-là que je souhaite développer
de manière très forte une dimension sur
la territorialisation pour avoir un
ancrage au niveau des territoires on le
sait et et et notamment aussi sur le bon
usage si les choses bougent elles
bougent au niveau local on le voit il y
a et on a un réseau de correspondant de
médecins et de pharmaciens au niveau
local dans l'ensemble des régions y
compris y compris en outreem et on le
voit bien on l' à la fois des remontées
mais également par rapport aux mesures
que l'on propose au niveau national
comment elles sont appliquées est-ce
qu'elles sont comprises et l'échelon
local l'échelon territorial est
indispensable donc vraiment c'est un
enjeu pour le COP qui est de 5 ans si
j'ai l'honneur de de pouvoir continuer à
diriger cette maison je ne serai plus là
en effet dans 3 ans la loi arrête en
effet c'est uniquement de mandats mais
en effet développer de manière
extrêmement forte cette territor
territorial isation cette adaptation en
effet on le voit bien il y a des
typologies aussi de patientelles qui
sont différentes et c'est indispensable
d'avoir cette cette collaboration et
notamment avec le réseau des agences
régionales de santé et une agence
performante et engagée puisque pour
délivrer au mieux pour l'ensemble des
concit des concitoyens il faut que
évidemment l'ensemble de mes équipes les
voilà les plus de 1000 agents que que
j'ai l'honneur à nouveau de à nouveau de
de diriger et une qualité de vie au
travail évidemment adéquate nous somm
som très attentif je suis très attentif
à l'équilibre des temps de vie entre la
vie professionnelle et la vie
personnelle ce n'est pas toujours simple
c'est une agence de sécurité sanitaire
c'est une une agence d'urgence aussi
donc il n'est pas forcément toujours
simple en effet de pouvoir concilier
mais c'est évidemment extrêmement
important pour conserver cette capacité
d'écoute cette capacité d'expertise
cette capacité d'agilité et également
aussi pour renforcer notre attractivité
puisqu'on le sait c'est une maison c'est
c'est une belle institution mais c'est
une maison qui est exigeante c'est des
missions qui sont extrêmement exigeantes
et donc voilà il faut que nous soyons
attractifs pour pouvoir à la fois
attirer et conserver les talents que
nous avons au sein de l'agence je
conclus mes propos en soulignant
l'importance de l'évolution de l'agence
depuis depuis ces trois dernières années
mais aussi fortement engagé depuis 2016
et si l'opportunité m'est donné de
poursuivre mes fonctions auprès des
collaborateurs de l'agence je
m'emploirai à chaque instant à ce que la
NSM soit et reste une agence à l'écoute
de ses usagers de leurs attentes capable
d'être agile et résolument en prise avec
son temps une agence au service de la
sécurité de tous les patients qui
utilisent des produits de santé de
nombreux progrès ont déjà eu lieu ont
été réalisés mais il y a encore du
chemin à parcourir et c'est dans ce
cadre- là que je vous présente je me
présente en effet devant vous
aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup hop merci beaucoup pour votre
présentation alors je vais commencer par
vous poser deux questions et ensuite on
donnera la parole à l'ensemble des
sénateurs elles sont relativement simple
vous avez en parti répondu mais vous
venez de présenter votre projet et
l'ambition que vous aviez pour l'agence
on sait que vous êtes en pleine
discussion pour la mise en place du
nouveau contrat d'objectif et de
performance comment se passent ces
discussions justement pour la nouvelle
mouture du contrat à venir voilà et puis
l'autre question est très liée à la
commission d'enquête sur la pénuie du
médicament qui avait été réalisée aussi
Sénat lors de la commission d'enquête
vous avez beaucoup évoqué le manque de
moyens de l'agence pour contrôler le
respect des obligations de l'ensemble
des acteurs de la chaîne du
médicamentens et prendre les mesures
nécessaires à la prévention et la
résolution des situations de rupture
nous avons vu que dans le le budget la
dotation pour 2024 était légèrement
augmenté qui dorait se traduire par
environ 7 équal en temps plein est-ce
que vous pensez qu'avec cette
augmentation vous aurez les moyens de
pouvoir j' dirais régler ces difficultés
et notamment dans ce domaine quels sont
vos vos chantiers prioritaires tout ça
simpement je vous laisse
répondre merci beaucoup monsieur
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur alors en effet je je l'ai dit
nous sommes à l'Ô d'un nouveau COP notre
contrat d'objectif et et de performance
donc sous la tutelle évidemment de la
Direction générale de la santé mais
également aussi de notre tutelle
budgétaire la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale l'ensemble des directions
d'administration centrale et également
aussi la direction du budget la
Direction de la recherche également donc
dans le cadre en effet classique de la
mobilisation d'un d'un nouveau COP il y
a une mission IGAS qui donc qui est
mobilisée pour le bilan du COP et tracer
les grandes les grands axes donc qui qui
en effet c'est c'est terminé le rapport
est encore est encore en effet
confidentiel on a déjà évidemment des
des premiers éléments qui voilà qui qui
tracent en effet un bilan et et j'ose le
dire positif selon les termes avec
évidemment des marges des marges de
progression et heureusement si sinon
voilà c'est je pas que ça serait un
petit peu triste mais mais pour autant
il y a toujours évidemment des marges
des marges des marges de progression et
donc ensuite tout un travail qui est
réalisé en effet en étroite
collaboration avec les tutelles et avec
donc à la fois sur les axes stratégi qui
doivent être qui donc qui sont qui sont
présentés comme voilà ce ce que je vous
ai présenté nous avons une discussion au
sein de notre conseil d'administration
puisque évidemment le COP doit être
validé par notre conseil
d'administration nous avons une une une
discussion en effet lors de notre
conseil d'administration de fin
septembre avec les les les ambitions et
donc ce que je vous ai en effet présenté
a été présenté au conseil
d'administration et les grands axes ont
été ont été en effet validés et et avec
et dans notre conseil d'administration
et évidemment vous le savez toutes et
tous il y a des parlementaires donc
trois sénateurs évidemment sont présents
trois trois députés également des
représentants de professionnels de santé
d'usager le vice-président de notre
conseil d'administration est un
représentant d'usager euh et la
présidente du conseil d'administration
est un membre du Conseil d'État et donc
nous sommes donc déjà les grands axes en
effet que je vous ai présenté voilà on
on recueillit l'aval en effet notamment
de notre conseil d'administration voilà
mettant en évidence l'adéquation de ces
axes et ensuite il y a le travail plus
on va dire plus précis de rédaction à la
fois des actions des thèmes des
indicateurs et avec un objectif en effet
que nous puissions avoir un COP finalisé
présenter à notre conseil
d'administration de fin juin et signé
ensuite entre euh le ou la directrice
générale de de la NSM donc en fin juin
2024 début juillet et le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention et sur le les
moyens de médic alors concernant en
effet les moyens et donc en effet j'ai
j'ai eu j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
être auditionné deux fois par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur sur
les pénuries euh évidemment en effet sur
le sujet des moyens cela avait été
indiqué la nécessité de pouvoir être en
capacité de à la fois sur l'ensemble des
actions relatives aux pénuries avec des
dimensions et je le disais aussi des
compétences diversifiées pour la NSM
aujourd'hui notamment sur le sujet de la
régulation il y a la nécessité et nous
analysons des centaines de milliers de
données puisque nous regardons si je
prends l'exemple de laamoxyiline mais
pas que sur l'ensemble des molécules du
plan hivernal nous regardons
l'approvisionnement ligne par ligne donc
industrielle par industrielle spécialité
par spécialité à la fois au niveau des
industriels mais aussi des grossistes
répartiteurs mais aussi des officines
donc ce sont des des données voilà un
nombre de données gigantesques euh et
donc il y a la nécessité d'aller de
s'enrichir de compétences nouvelles de
Data scientist de voilà de de de
d'analyse d'expert de la donnée et donc
en effet les SEP TP qui ont été octroyé
à la NSN c'est quelque chose de positif
alors classiquement je dirais que voilà
7 est en effet quelque chose de très
bien nous avions sollicité en effet plus
mais voilà mais c'est voilà c'est déjà
extrêmement important et notamment dans
le cadre le contexte des finances
publiques c'est un un effort évidemment
important et nous allons nous employer
en effet à les utiliser évidemment comme
chaque ETP que nous avons de la manière
la plus adéquate possible notamment par
rapport à des profils et des
compétences renforcé sur cette gestion
en effet de données cette gestion de
flux aussi on y reviendra peut-être sur
le ultérieurement sur sur d'autres
sujets cette gestion de flux et donc
pour en effet analyser l'ensemble des
données les données de prescription les
données d'usage en effet puisque
j'indiquais nous sommes dans une
situation de grosse consommation et donc
voilàessayer de voir comment on articule
à la fois le bon usage et le sujet et le
sujet évidemment rupture et les
obligations en effet vérifier les
obligations de de chaque de chaque
industriel merci beaucoup alors je vais
donner la parole tout d'abord à
corinbert qui est rapporteur de la
branche maladie
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la Directrice pour votre
présentation tout
d'abord une remarque vous dire que je
partage avec vous ce souci par rapport à
la consommation de médicaments le souci
de la juste prescription de la juste
consommation et à titre personnel j'ai
toujours dit aux patients que
médicaments n'étaient pas des smartisés
pardonnez-moi cette page de publicité
mais c'est une réalité qu'il est bon de
de
rappeler j'ai bien entendu votre
attachement à à décliner euh les les
missions de la NSM à l'échelon local ça
passe par la confiance des acteurs
notamment la confiance dans les
professionnels de santé voilà pour pour
mes premières remarques alors j'ai
plusieurs questions vous l'imaginez bien
tout d'abord je vais revenir sur les
discussions du du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 puisque le Sénat avait adopté un
amendement qui miracle a été conservé
dans le texte du
Gouvernement engagé quand il engagé sa
responsabilité à l'Assemblée nationale
et qui consiste après une procédure
contradictoire d'intégrer à la liste des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur un médicament n'étant pas
considéré comme tel par l'entreprise qui
l'exploite de quelle manière et selon
quel calendrier comptez-vous vous
emparer de cette nouvelle faculté
devrait-elle permettre par exemple
d'intégrer à la liste des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur le
paracétamol bien connu de de tous qui a
concentré ces dernières années des
difficultés d'approvisionnement et qui
continue à rencontrer des des
difficultés pour certaines
spécialité euh deuxè question
euh les récentes recommandations de la
NSM visant à dissuader le la la la
consommation l'utilisation de
l'asoconstricteur pour soulager les
symptômes du rhume voilà qui était
commercialisé depuis peut-être plus de
20 ans dans certaines spécialités ne
risque-t-elle pas donc ces récentes
recommandations je ne les remets pas en
cause bien évidemment mais ne
risque-t-elle pas de nourrir euh la
défiance des des Français vis-à-vis des
médicaments et des vaccins faisons large
et comment l'agence tient-elle compte de
cette crise de confiance et comment
entendez-vous y répondre dans les
prochaines années près de 15 ans après
le scandale du du Médiator et après 3
ans passé à la tête de l'agence
estimez-vous que la confiance dans le
médicament et les vaccins hein et les
autorités de pharmacovigilance s
amélioré en
France 3è question vous avez évoqué
aussi le sujet c'est le casadre des
accès dérogatoires qui a été largement
revu en loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2021 avec le
remplacement des autorisations et
recommandations temporaires
d'utilisation par les accès précoces et
dérogatoires comment ce changement
a-t-il influé sur l'activité de la NSM
dans les procédures dérogatoires et quel
bilan tirez-vous à ce jour de la
procédure d'accès compassionnel pour
laquelle la NSM joue un rôle
prépondérant et au-delà de l'aspect
financier quelles sont selon vous les
marges de manœuvre et les marges de
progression restante pour améliorer
l'accès des Français au mé mic innovant
les critiques par voie formulé par les
patients et les industriels sur ce point
selon selon selon vous sont-elles
justifi j'ai deux autres questions et je
m'en arrêterai là que pensez-vous de la
contradiction entre obligation de
sérialisation et dispensation à
l'unité et euh et là pardonnez-moi mon
insolence et je suis contre enfin je
suis pas favorable à l'utilisation des
somnifères mais est-ce que les pénuries
de médicament vous empêchent de dormir
parce que méfiez-vous il y a un souniver
en ce moment qui rencontre des
difficultés d'approvisionnement je vous
remercie Madame la Directrice merci
Madame Ambert je donne la parole
maintenant à Laurence müer
Brown merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice merci pour votre
présentation enthousiaste et courageuse
c'est vrai que vous sortez d'un mandat
qui est loin d'être serein et donc on
vous on vous on souhaite un deuxième
mandat mais est plus calme quand même on
vous souhaite donc euh moi j'auraai des
questions autour de deux rapports euh
d'abord le rapport de notre commission
d'enquête sur la peénuriie des
médicaments j'étais membre de cette
commission et ensuite sur le rapport de
l'obset de juin 2022 de l'OPEX pardon de
juin 2022 alors concernant les gestions
de pénuries de médicaments à l'échelon
local nous avions constaté une absence
de coordination entre l'anssm et les les
agences régional de santé qui aggravait
considérablement la situation qu'en
est-il aujourd'hui s'agissant des
pouvoirs de sanction dont la NSM dispose
pour le non respect des obligations de
stock des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
nous avions constaté qu'ils sont très
peu utilisé l'agence n'a pris que H
décisions de sanction financières entre
2018 et 2022 un montant total de 922000
€. ces sanctions prononcées par l' NSM
apparaissent particulièrement faibles
dans leur nombre et dans leur montants
aucune n'a été prise pour le motif d'une
violation des obligations d'élaboration
d'un plan de gestion de pénurie et de
consultation d'un stock de sécurité par
les industriels quels sont vos objectifs
donc pour rendre le pouvoir de contrôle
et de sanctions de l'anssm dissuasif
auprès des laboratoires en février
dernier les ministres de la Santé et de
l'industrie ont annoncé la mise en place
sous 3 mois et en lien avec l' NSM d'un
plan de praration des épidémies
hivernales pourtant la pénurie
d'antibiotique tel que l'amoxicyine
perdure quel est ce plan et où en
est-il sur le rapport de l'opexte là
j'enviendrai aux effets indésirables des
vaccins contre la
covid-19 concernant la pharmacovigilance
vous l'avez abordé sur les effets
indésirables des médicaments et des
vaccins le rapport de l'opexte a fait
état des lacunes du système de
déclaration passif seul 5 à 10 % des
événements indésirables sont notifiés ce
qui peut engendrer une sous-estimation
d'une de l'ampleur d'un problème
sanitaire le manque d'information en
direction des patients d'une part et de
formation des professionnels de santé à
la pharmacovigilance d'autre part sont
des lacunes qui ont été bien identifiées
dans ce rapport quels sont vos objectifs
pour améliorer les dispositifs de
déclaration et rendre les procédures de
déclaration accessibles à tous
professionnels de santé comme
patient et enfin dernière question
reconnaître la souffrance liée aux
effets
indésirable la confiance se construit
sur la reconnaissance il semble
important de reconnaître l'existence de
certains effets indésirable qu'il
prennent une forme le plus souvent
bénine et parfois grave à ce titre les
rapporteurs de ce rapport de l'OPEX
regrette que l'anssm ne soit pas ne se
soit pas prononcé à l'échelle nation
nation sur l'existence d'un lien entre
les troubles menstruels et certains
vaccins contre le covid-19 en l'absence
de prise de position du comité de
pharmacovigilance européen alors que les
centres régionaux de pharmacovigilance
ont reconnu la pertinence de ce
signal voilà Madame la Directrice merci
merci on continue la parole à Bernard
jemier merci monsieur le Président merci
Madame la Directrice je voudrais vous
questionner sur deux points sur le
paquet pharmaceutique européen et sur la
démocratie sanitaire sur le paquet
pharmaceutique européen qui est en en
préparation donc avec Pascal grunny et
Cathy AP poursopoli on est chargé d'un
d'un avis pour la commission des
affaires européennes donc on procède
actuellement à des auditions et j'aurais
voulu d'abord que vous nous fassiez part
de votre avis sur l'orientation générale
de ce projet de paquet pharmaceutique
européen avec trois points en
particulier d'abord la commission
aim l'option concernant le stockage des
médicaments de le confier plutôt à
l'Union et aux États-membres que aux
entreprises qui est le cas actuellement
en France dans notre pays donc comment
vous vous voyez cette cette évolution
deuxièmement il est proposé de supprimer
la procédure de renouvellement des
autorisations de mise sur le marché au
bout de 5 années pour les médicaments
qui ont été mis sur le marché il y a
plus de 5 ans donc pareil même question
et tr ement il est prévu d'établir une
liste de médicaments critiques donc on
se souvient des débats dans notre pays
lorsqu'une liste similaire a
été publié par le ministère de la
Santé comment voyez-vous l'laboration
d'une telle liste est-ce qu'elle doit
s'applier sur des molécules sur des
groupes pharmaceutiques voilà j'aurais
voulu avoir votre avis 2uxè point la
démocratie sanitaire donc c'est un sujet
auquel sur lequel vous vous exprimez
beaucoup quand vous avez été nommé vous
avez affirmé votre attachement à la
démocratie sanitaire vous avez débuté
votre exposé par cette question et
pourtant on a tout de même l'impression
que votre agence écoute assez peu les
associations de patients écoute beaucoup
plus les industriels depuis que vous
êtes directrice votre agence a été mise
en examen pour tromperie
euh on se souvient que sur le
levoyox au fond il s'est révélé que le
laboratoire avait omis délibérément ou
pas je ne sais pas enfin n'avait pas
mentionné sur ces boîtes un changement
de composition et que l'agence est resté
silencieuse donc voilà on apprécie votre
votre discours sur la démocratie
sanitaire mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire concrètement quel dispositif
vous comptez mettre en place parce que
pour le moment c'est plutôt la vie des
industriels qui prime très largement et
nous en avons l'impression au-delà du
raisonnable parfois et au-delà de la
réalité scientifique je vous remci très
bien Madame je vous propose de répondre
à ces trois séries de questions et
ensuite nous avons 5 intervenants
encore merci beaucoup euh merci beaucoup
pour pour ces questions alors concernant
euh concernant en effet le sujet euh euh
au niveau du PLFSS et des mesures en
effet sur les MITM et la capacité de
pouvoir euh faire entrer un médicament
dans euh en tant que MITM ce qui n'était
pas le cas en effet au préalable puisque
c'est à la discrétion des industriels et
on le voit en effet sur un certain
nombre de sujet lorsque nous avons des
déclarations ou lorsque nous faisons le
constat remonté par des pharmaciens ou
par des patients de de de difficultés
sur certains médicaments s'il ne rentre
pas en effet dans la définition et la
définition est claire d'un médicament
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur cela
emmène en effet beaucoup de conséquences
puisque'il n'y a pas d'obligation de
stock pas d'obligation pour les les
industriels donc très clairement là on
effit en terme de en terme de processus
sur la base déjà des remontées des
disparités que nous avons et donc cela
va nous permettre en effet de pouvoir
définir et d'ajouter un certain nombre
de spécialités en tant que MITM on là
par exemple sur une substance active on
peut avoir certaines spécialités
certains industriels qui ont classés en
MITM et d'autres pas déjà euh je dirais
au fil de l'eau lorsque nous voyons des
disparités nous demandons en effet à
l'industriel là nous av allons avoir la
possibilité de pouvoir les intégrer le
sujet du paracétamol en effet est est un
point important et notamment sur le
sujet du paracétamol pédiatrique sur le
parestamol de manière générale adulte la
question peut possiblement en effet se
poser par rapport à la définition réelle
du voilà de de du statut MITM
typiquement pour le paracétamol
pédiatrique je suis assez intimement
convaincu que cela répond à la
définition en effet d'un médicament
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur et donc
nous aurons la possibilité cette fois-ci
de pouvoir en effet le faire y compris
si si l'industriel n'est pas dans cette
n'est pas dans cette dynamique euh le
sujet des vasaux constructeurs pardon le
sujet des vasaux constructeurs euro en
effet vous l'avez vous l'avez vous
l'avez en effet indiqué madame la
sénatrice avec une recommandation forte
de des professionnels de santé des
pharmaciens des médecins et de la NSM de
ne pas utiliser les vasau constructeur
euro ce sont des médicaments qui sont
commercialisés depuis des années qui
sont commercialisés au niveau européen
et c'est là raison pour laquelle il y a
besoin de l'avis de de l'Agence
européenne du médicament pour une
décision de suspension donc définitive
notamment des autorisations de mise sur
le marché nous n'avons pas le même la
même appréciation en effet que l'agence
européenne vous avez dû vous avez dû le
voir nous nous considérons en effet
que évidemment on évalue le rapport
bénéfice risque en fonction des
situations les basau constructeurs eurau
vous l'avez indiqué sont là pour
soulager un symptôme Bénin ça ne voilà
il vas au constrict très bien ça
débouche le nez le problème c'est qu'il
vas au constrict aussi ailleurs et donc
avec des risques certes très rares mais
très grave d'AVC d'accident vasculaire
cérébral ou d'infarctus du myocarde et
donc très clairement risquer un AVC pour
un nez bouché je ne suis pas sûr en
effet que cela soit complètement adéquat
d'où la mobilisation de l'ensemble même
si c'est extrêmement rare c'est très
très rare mais pour autant il nous
apparaît en effet avec les médecins avec
les pharmaciens que voilà il est voilà
des recommandations voilà d'utilisation
de sérum physiologique ou d'eau de mer
sont beaucoup plus adéquat l'Europe n'a
pas cette perception elle il y a eu un
premier avis du comité de sécurité avec
un ajout de deux nouvelles
contre-indications on avait 16
contre-indications che C vas au
constructeur euro on en a maintenant 18
ça fait un peu beaucoup et donc nous
notre position en effet est différente
ces autorisations de missieur le marché
elles sont là puisqueen effet au niveau
européen et elles resteront pour autant
l'autorité SAN ire en effet que je
dirige avec les médecins avec les
pharmaciens nous considérons en effet
qu'il faut aller qu'il faut en effet
aller plus loin sur le sujet de la
défiance ou de la méfiance en effet
c'est le rôle majeur et vous l'avez
indiqué madame la sénatrice de la
confiance et de l'échange au quotidien
entre les patients et leurs
professionnels de santé avec leurs
médecins avec le pharmacien on a la
chance en effet d'avoir un maillage
territorial notamment au niveau
officinal qui est extrêmement précieux
et donc des échanges et on le VO dans
les enquêtes en effet de dans les
enquêtes d'opinion le patient le a
confiance en son médecin et a confiance
en son pharmacien c'est la raison pour
laquelle en effet nous travaillons au
quotidien et je reviendrai en effet sur
la question de la démocratie sanitaire
avec avec avec des évidemment j'y
répondrai des propos mais qui me qui
enfin qui me touchent et qui et je
dirais qui me blaisse parce que depuis
en tout cas je que je suis à la NSM et
même depuis 2011 vous savez mon
implication dans la loi de 2011 j'ai eu
la chance de la porter lorsque j'étais
en effet au au cabinet santé le fond
d'indemnisation la loi médiat je n'ai de
cesse et je peux vous garantir je n'ai
de cesse d'écouter l'ensemble des
parties prenantes et les patients les
usagers sont dans l'ensemble des de nos
instances de gouvernance et de nos
instances de décision notamment dans le
cadre du du rapport en effet sur le COP
les parties prenantes ont été
interrogées les usagers ont été
interrogés France àous santé et d'autres
et reconnaissent l'évolution il y a
toujours des choses perfectibles il faut
toujours mieux faire mais aujourd'hui et
je le dis très son solennellement aucun
document aucune information aucune
recommandation de la NSM ne sort sans
qu'il y ait eu des échanges avec les
professionnels de santé et avec les
patients y compris sur les ruptures
notamment sur les ruptures lorsqu'on
doit on doit s'engager vers d'autres
traitements donc réellement les cooutes
en effet des usagers est quelque chose
de card et de primordial sinon je ne
ferai pas ce métier très clairement et
c'est vraiment un point un point majeur
donc il y a des efforts en effet à la
fois de encore de communication des
efforts de de description de comment
nous fonctionnons la preuve en est
puisque en tout cas il y a une
perception qui est qui est différente et
avec une étanchéité totale notamment
évidemment avec les industriels voilà
les industriel évidemment produisent des
médicaments et et et j'aimerais qu'il
les produisent en nombre qui permettrait
quand même de garantir la couverture des
besoins mais donc nous avons depuis la
loi de 2011 il n'y a plus aucun
industriel au représentant d'industriel
dans nos instance très clairement on a
un comité d'interface puisqu'il doit y
avoir en effet des échanges qui sont
tracés avec des ordres du jour avec des
compte-rendus qui sont en ligne sur
notre site Internet et très clairement
la parole des usagers et la prise en
compte on peut ne pas toujours être
d'accord évidemment mais en tout cas
c'est échangé c'est débattu on a
différents formats par exemple les
comités scientifiques temporaires qui
sont mis en place sur des sujets
spécifiques vous l'avez peut-être vu
nous venons de mettre en place un comité
sur les agonistes du GLP1 aux ENIC aux
ique et donc de ce fait évidemment un
point et avec dans ce comité les
représentants des patients sur le sujet
du le sujet également euh le sujet sur
alors oui sérialisation et dau
sérialisation et dau
euh sérialisation et dau voilà tout à
fait euh évidemment voilà nous sommes
dans une situation qui est assez assez
orthogonale je pense que le sujet de la
dispensation à
l'unité est une option qui peut-être
mobilisée dans des cas spécifiques très
spécifiques en effet aujourd'hui on le
voit ce qui est important notamment sur
le bon usage c'est l'adéquation des
conditionnements par rapport à la durée
de prescription et c'est un travail en
effet qui est réalisé à la fois par la
NSM mais aussi la Haute Autorité de
Santé pour essayer d'avoir une
adéquation importante typiquement si je
prends l'exemple des boîtes d'amoxyyine
on a on a 6 jours en effet de traitement
les les les recommandation évolue plutôt
sur 5 jours et bien il faudra adapter et
en effet c'est plus adéquat d'adapter en
effet un conditionnement que voilà par
contre la dispensation à l'unité en
effet est une modalité qui peut être
mobilisée mais je partage en effet que
sérialisation et dau nous ne sommes pas
complètement sur des parallèles je suis
assez assez d'accord avec vous est-ce
que les pénuries de médicaments euh
m'empêche voilà m'empêche m'empêche de
dormir elle me préoccupe oui elle me
préoccupe évidemment comme tout citoyen
comme comme nous toutes et tous je le
disais je le rappelle hein évidemment et
ça fait le le plan le le lien aussi avec
les questions qui ont été posé sur le
rapport de la de la commission
d'enquête un point majeur que je
souhaite rappeler euh et et c'est
évidemment dans le casre de la
réglementation lorsqu'un industriel a
une autorisation de mise sur le marché
dépose une demande àme et a une
autorisation il s'engage aussi à
garantir la couverture et
l'approvisionnement en en du quantité
par rapport à la population cible qu'il
a estimé donc la la première en effet
responsabilité c'est que l'industriel
doit être en capacité de pouvoir en
effet garantir un approvisionn un
approvisionnement ensuite des problèmes
de production des incidents oui
évidemment cela existe et ça c'est c'est
voilà cela arrive mais pour autant euh
au tout début en effet il faut bien
évidemment qu'il y ait cette cette
responsabilité et cette capacité
d'approvisionner d'approvisionner le
marché si en effet il y a une
autorisation de mise sur le marché et
qu'au final l'industriel n'est pas en
capacité c'est voilà c'est une tromperie
pour le patient et le professionnel de
santé parce qu'on donne une autorisation
on donne un espoir possiblement de
traitement et en fait derrière il n'y a
pas le médicament donc ça c'est un point
qui est évidemment voilà évidemment
extrêmement important sur le sujet des
sanctions financières et je m'en étais
exprimé en effet notamment au lors de la
des auditions de la commission d'enquête
en effet entre 2018 et 2022 un nombre
restreint très restreint de sanctions
financières euh eu égard notamment au
périmètres qui étaient accordés qui
étaiit poss possible pour les sanctions
financières à partir de fin 2022 et sur
2023 le le périmètre en effet des des
des des critères sanctionnables a été
élargi et euh donc en 2023 il y a déjà
eu h sanctions financières ce qui est
beaucoup plus puisqueentre 2018 et 2000
22 je crois qu'il n'y avait eu que 8
sanctions financières qui sont
aujourd'hui uniquement dédié aux
pénuries l'objectif n'est pas de dire
qu'il faut absolument que ce soit sur
les pénuries mais pour autant en effet
un accent plus important sur le sujet le
sujet des pénuries concernant le montant
cela je crois que vous avez souligné en
effet le montant le montant est défini
dans les textes c'est-à-dire que je ne
et c'est un seuil maximal je suis désolé
je ne suis pas en capacité de vous de
vous de vous indiquer précisément mais
c'est un montant maximal euh qui est
défini dans les textes et donc je ne
peux pas aller au-delà en effet de ce
montant maximal il y a le sujet du
montant puis il y a le sujet aussi de la
publicité de la communication on le sait
il y a un montant c'est c'est évidemment
quelque chose d'important mais la
communication la publicité de la
sanction est évidemment aussi quelque
chose d'important aujourd'hui les textes
aussi imposent que cette communication
soit seulement d'un mois sur le site
internet de la NSM je ne peux pas aller
au-delà d'un mois c'est très court c'est
en effet très court il faut euh cibler
euh voilà pour que ce soit visible il
faut cibler évidemment le mois donc
c'est ce sont peut-être et sous le sous
le contrôle en effet de de de ma
directrice réglementation et déontologie
qui est
présente c'est du niveau législatif je
crois et donc pour faire bouger ou faire
évoluer en effet puisque aujourd'hui
cela ne peut être qu'un mois
euh sur le sujet du plan hivernal en
effet donc oui donc cela nous a été
demandé en février
2023 février 2023 et donc nous avons mis
en place en effet un plan hivernal qui a
été construit avec l'ensemble des
acteurs les professionnels de santé donc
les médecins les pharmaciens les
patients avec l'ensemble aussi des
directions et des échanges aussi avec
les directions d'administration centrale
et qui a été communiqué au mois
d'octobre avec trois dimensions une
dimension de surveillance une une
dimension d'activation de mesures et
aussi une dimension de rétex évidemment
à l'issue de voilà de la de la période
donc nous suivons un certain nombre de
molécule marqueur donc sur les
médicaments qui sont utilisés pendant
les pathologies vernales les
antibiotiques les corticoïdes le
paracétamol également fluticazon et
salbutamol qui sont des médicaments
utilisés notamment dans les pathologies
les pathologies
asthmatiques la situation sur le
paracétamol en effet par rapport à l'an
dernier c'est normalisé y compris en
terme d'accès pour les patients
c'est-à-dire que il y a des stocks
importants chez les industriel il y en a
chez les grossites et il y en a dans les
officines la moxicyine en effet nous
sommes dans une sit situation sur les
causes racines qui est extrêmement
différente par rapport à l'an dernier
pour autant le patient aujourd'hui a
d'énormes difficultés de pouvoir et les
pharmaciens évidemment aussi de pouvoir
avoir accès à son traitement dans dans
son officine au niveau notamment au
niveau local l'année dernière il y avait
une pénurie de de d'approvisionnement
une pénurie de production les
industriels en effet voilà ENF la
production n'était pas à la hauteur de
de la flambée épidémieque que nous avons
eu la triple épidémie ém extrêmement
précoce l'an dernier et donc il y avait
une pénurie d'approvisionnement il n'y
avait pas assez d'amoxyinine aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans des difficultés dans
une pénuerie de distribution il y a des
stocks au niveau industriel les les
spécialités en effet existent mais la
répartition sur le territoire national
est extrêmement hétérogène avec des
situations et dans dans certains cas en
effet des stocks d'amoxyiline que ce
soit pédiatrique ou ou adulte important
et dans d'autres cas et dans un nombre
de cas extrêmement important une une un
non acccès en effet au aux spécialités
aux amoxyilin c'est la raison pour
laquelle en effet vous le savez dans le
circuit aujourd'hui il y a deux façons
d'approvisionner les officines soit des
ventes directes directement des
industriels donc des dépositaires
vis-à-vis des officines ou alors en
passant par les grossistes répartiteurs
qui sont il y a 180 agences de
répartition qui ont des obligations de
service public pour approvisionner de
manière équitable l'ensemble du
territoire national sur ces produits la
moxyyine et les autres produits donc en
effet qui sont tombés dans le domaine
public les majoritairement des
médicaments génériques normalement il y
a 80 % des flux qui passent par les
grossistes répartiteurs et 20 % en vente
directe ce qu'on a constaté en effet sur
2023 c'est une dérégulation du système
avec quasiment rien chez les grossistes
répartiteurs et uniquement des ventes
directes qui ne permet pas de garantir
ce cette ce maillage en effet
territorial et c'est la raison pour
laquelle a été mobilisé à la fois
l'appel à la responsabilisation de
chaque acteur je l'ai dit et je l'ai dit
en effet il y a quelques il y a un petit
peu plus de un petit peu plus de 2 heur
voilà dans la lors de ma précédente
audition ce sont des relations
évidemment entre acteurs et entre
acteurs privés l'agence est là et nous
avons des missions de garantie de la
couverture mais nous n'avons pas de
baguette magique très clairement nous
n'avons pas nous voilà nous ne
produisons pas de médicaments nous
n'avons pas non plus de camion qui
approvisionne il faut qu'il y ait la
responsabilisation de chacun des acteurs
et que le seul objectif de
l'approvisionnement là soit un objectif
de santé publique pour que chaque
patient chaque officine en effet puisse
disposer de ces médicaments qui existent
he les stocks existent et puissent être
accessibl d'où la charte d'engagement
qui a été mise en place donc qui a été
signée par l'ensemble des acteurs sous
la coordination de la présidente du du
knop et et de moi-même donc nous
coordonnons mais nous ne sommes pas
signateurs parce que nous ne sommes pas
acteurs de la chaîne et avec des
engagements où chaque acteur a
uniquement un engagement responsable ce
n'est pas opposable en effet ce n'est
pas opposable mais c'est évidemment un
engagement sur le sujet de de notamment
de l'OPEX et et et des et des vaccins et
sur la déclaration de pharmacovigilance
les déclarations en effet sont des
déclarations spontanées donc le
l'objectif est la la communication et la
capacité en effet à déclarer à la fois
par les professionnels de santé mais
également par les patients c'est
possible en effet déjà depuis de
nombreuses années avec un portail en
effet unique euh et et on le voit y
compris à la fois sur d'autres sujets
mais également le sujet des vaccins avec
des déclarations qui ont quand même été
importantes pour autant en effet
lorsqu'on est sur des déclarations
spontanées il y a toujours une
sous-notification c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand nous avons mobilisé la
surveillance sur les vaccin mais sur
d'autres sujets aussi il y a je dirais
deux jambes il y a les déclarations
spontanées donc la pharmacovigilance et
il y a la
pharmacoépidémiologie notamment avec
épipar en effet notre Groupement
d'Intérêt Scientifique dans les bases de
données de l'assurance maladie qui
permet en effet de d'avoir notamment sur
les vaccins covid et tous les rapports
sont évidemment en ligne et on fait
l'objet aussi d'articles internationaux
d'avoir en en vie réelle et en
permanence les données d'efficacité et
de sécurité sur sur le sujet en effet
des des effets des effets indésirables
donc c'est vraiment les deux ensembles
on l'a aussi sur d'autres a re
sujet le sujet de la reconnaissance de
la souffrance des effets indésirables je
partage en effet la confiance est
importante c'est la raison pour laquelle
en effet je je dis la la la la présence
des patients et la parole des patients
est est est constante en effet au niveau
de la NSM et la reconnaissance est
importante sur le sujet des troubles
menstruels très clairement le sujet des
troubles menstruels ont été reconnus par
la NSM nous avons cl voilà nous avons
clairement et c'est c'est la NSM
notamment qui l'a porté au niveau
européen à nouveau la perception
européenne nous sommes un État membre
parmi tant d'autres mais c'est ce que
j'indiquais aussi le fait d'avoir une
force de plus en plus
importante les recommandations en effet
au niveau de l'Agence européenne du
médicament n'ont pas été aussi loin que
ce que nous avons pu en effet mobiliser
mais pour autant c'est notre devoir en
effet de porter lorsque nous avons des
effets indésirables au niveau au niveau
national de les porter au niveau
européen et également ép part regarde
aussi ce qu'il se passe sur ce
sujet du conseil d'administration de
l'IM en effet sur les comités
scientifiques voilà ce ne sont pas les
comités scientifiques mais pour autant
la le sujet trouble menstruel a été
porté par la NSM et c'est ce qui a
permis en effet aussi que ça soit étudié
au niveau européen on peut ne pas être
satisfait de l'issue de l'évaluation
européenne mais pour autant cela a quand
même permis et en effet la France et
l'État qui qui signale le plus parce que
nous avons un système de
pharmacovigilance qui est probablement
plus performant que d'autres États et
donc nous signalons en effet de manière
importante au niveau de l'Agence
européenne des médicaments
euh sur la démocratie sanitaire je pense
que j'ai j'ai répondu sur le par sur le
paquet pardon pharmaceutique européen le
sujet en effet sur les stockages de
médicaments plutôt au niveau des
États-membres ou de l'Union cela peut
s'entendre sur un nombre limité
possiblement en effet dans une
philosophie de stock stratégique
pourquoi pas mais sur un nombre limité
l'importance en effet c'est de pouvoir
avoir cette mutualisation qui existe
déjà aujourd'hui lorsque nous avons des
situations de tension on on échange avec
nos homologues européens pour voir si
par exemple ils ont des quantités et
inversement mais pour autant sur le
sujet des stocks en effet européens ça
cela pourrait s'envisager et c'est dans
le cadre des discussions mais uniquement
sur une liste une liste limitée
concernant la liste des médicaments
critiques vous avez dû le voir elle est
parue hier la liste des médicaments
critiques en effet de l'Union donc
réalisé par l'Agence européenne du
médicament donc sous mandat de de
l'Union européenne auquel nous avons
travaillé en effet de manière active
aussi on est on est de mémoire sur 200
médicaments alors dès qu'on parle de
liste de toute façon c'est évidemment un
sujet sensible chaque État à une liste
avec un nombre qui est qui est différent
là le sujet était qui il y ait aussi une
notion de de criticité au moins dans un
tiers des États européens parce que
sinon nous nous aurions enfin la liste
européenne aurait été une justxte
apposition de l'ensemble des listes
nationales et avec un sujet en effet
possiblement d'évolution et de mise à
jour mais elle est sortie en effet le
donc elle est elle est sortie en effet
hier et avec des mesures et des
obligations qui interviendront
uniquement lorsque la révision de la
législation pharmaceutique sera
approuvée donc évidemment dans un temps
beaucoup plus
long très bien sur sur le renouvellement
oui alors sur alors le renouvellement
quinquenal est un
renouvellement assez administratif il y
a une surveillance en permanence de
toute façon au travers notamment ce
qu'on appelle des psures ou des psusas
c'est les rapports périodiques de
sécurité sur l'ensemble de la de la
substance active et donc ce suivi et
fait donc je pense que on évidemment on
ne perd pas en terme de d'évaluation et
de sécurité avec la suppression très
bien la parole à Pascal
Grun merci monsieur le Président Madame
directrice donc moi je voulais je
voulais revenir justement sur sur cette
liste des des médicaments parce que il y
avait aussi à la suite de ce travail que
les chaînes de production globale
matières premières produits finis ainsi
que les réseaux de distribution devait
être aussi
cartographié pour permettre de définir
justement la cri
industrielle de ces médicaments est-ce
que vous y travaillez avec avec le le
gouvernement et comment est-ce que vous
qualifier la collaboration des
industriels sur cette
question et ensuite en novembre dernier
été signé sous lesgit donc de l' insm et
du Conseil national de l'Ordre des
pharmaciens une charte visant à
améliorer l'information mutuelle entre
les différents acteurs de la chaîne de
distribution des médicaments les
différents signateurs s'engageaient
aussi ainsi en faveur d'une partition
équitable des stocks de médicaments sur
le territoire national et pourtant 2
semaines après cette signature la presse
indique que les grossistes répartiteurs
se plaignaient de ne disposer que de 3
jours de stock
d'amoxicyine alors que les stocks des
laboratoires sont de plusieurs mois
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dresser un
bilan de la mise en œuvre de cette
charte et enfit je vous ai entendu
parler d'homéopathti j'étais assez
étonné parce que je croyais que ça cé
interdit pour tout le
monde
alors donc oui mais mais en fait voilà
mais mais ma question oui oui je suis ta
kine parce que effectivement le le le
message en fait qui a été envoyé avec le
le dérembboursement ou le non
remboursement a fait que finalement
beaucoup moins de personnes vont se
soigner en homéopathie et moi moi je
m'étonne parce que je me suis aperçue
alors moi je savais que qu'on soignait
beaucoup les chevaux en homéopathie et
là je me suis j'ai j'ai vu que nos
éleveurs de
beauovin soigner aussi en homéopathie
leur vach pour éviter justement les
antibiotiques alors je me dis si c'est
bon pour les animaux est-ce que c'est
bon aussi pour l'homme voilà merci
beaucoup flance la
sarade je vais
rebondir tout d'abord comme
rapporteur sur les effets secondaires
des vaccins il me semble que les troubl
menstruel ont été souligné par ce
rapport et c'est dans juste après que la
NSM l'a proposé comme comme effet
secondairire si si on on revient je suis
un peu taquine
là mais c'est
oui donc je vais essayer d'être courte
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de de
questions auxquelles vous avez
répondu d'une part
la le dispositif pour évaluation des
dispositif méd invitro européen qui
existe depuis 18 mois a-t-il finalement
amélioré les choses est-ce qu'on a plus
de
remonté quelles sont les conséquences de
C de l'installation de cette agence
d'évaluation
ensuite pour revenir sur la pénurie de
d'amoxicyine moi qui étais pédiatre je
sais qu'en examinant correctement un
enfant les pédiatres prescrivent 50 %
d'antibiotiques en moins en particulier
grâce à l'utilisation des trodes comme
il n'y a quasiment plus de pédiatre
est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il
y ait à nouveau une explosion
d'utilisation
d'antibiotiques et est-ce que en France
on n'est pas
d'abord on devrait pas d'abord se poser
la question de savoir pourquoi la
prescription de médicaments particul
antibiotique est aussi importante avant
de se préoccuper de pénurie par ailleurs
pour ce qui concerne les vasau de
constriucteur orau dans les études de
médecine on mettait en garde contre les
vasau constricteurs qui soient locaux ou
euraux donc le problème c'est plutôt
l'automédication et ça est-ce que vous
avez un une vue particulière sur
l'automédication euh dernière question
un peu également que je vous pose pour
avoir votre position personnelle sur la
l'abandon des molécules qu'on utilisit
classiquement dans la maladie
d'Alzheimer sans sans évaluation
secondaire de l'abandon de ces molécules
et les nouveaux traitements
euh d'anticorp monoclonaux utilisés
actuellement aux États-Unis pour
l'Alzheimer qui en France ne sont pas
pour l'instant envisagés car la
pharmacovigilance insiste beaucoup sur
les effets secondaires mais est-ce
qu'oniniste pas sur les effets
secondaires justement pour ne pas avoir
à financer euh ces ces produits qui euh
en terme de de
coût représente quand même une dépense
importante merci beaucoup Céline mouin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice je revenir aussi sur le
travail de la commission d'enquête qui a
été beaucoup évoqué comme vous le
pressentiez commission d'enquête qui
avait notamment identifié qu'il avait
une qualité très inégale des plans de
gestion des
pénuries certains qui ne comportant pas
par exemple enfin ne comportant aucune
évaluation des risques de rupture et la
notre Commission a proposé lors de
l'examen du PLFSS 2024 la mise en place
de plan de gestion des pénuries renforcé
et le miracle évoqué tout à l'heure par
Corine hber n'a pas fait son effet sur
cette proposition puisqu'elle n'a pas
été retenue par le gouvernement donc
est-ce que vous envisagez est-ce que
votre agence envisage de renforcer les
contrôles en amont sur les contenus de
ces plans de gestion des peignuries
ensuite et rapidement vous avez évoqué
Pascal grunny vous a interrogé
là-dessus des pénuries qui toucherai au
aujourd'hui plus la distribution que la
production et le fait que tout en gros
ne passe pas par les grossistes
répartiteurs pose un problème en terme
de
maillage la charte que vous avez évoqué
et l'appel à la responsabilisation ne
semble en effet pas être complètement
opérante est-ce qu'il faudrait aller
plus loin que cette charte et dans quel
sens et enfin vous avez évoqué 8
sanctions financières d'ors et déjà en
2023 sanctions financières lié t
toujours à la pénurie de
médicament ce que ce qu'on peut comparer
au 8 qui avait été prononcé entre 2018
et 2022 est-ce que vous pouvez déjà
ressentir ou percevoir des effets de ces
sanctions des corrections de la part des
industriels ou est-ce qu'il est encore
trop tôt pour le dire MERCI MERCI
qualifi
qualifé merci monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup madame pour votre
présentation et permettez-moi de de vous
remercier de vive voix puisque je vous
ai sollicité vous étiez adjointe à
l'époque j'avais d'autres fonctions euh
pour la gestion du covid en moiselle sur
la pénurie de médicament et vous avez
usé de
votre regard de régulation pour nous
dépanner et ça a été très vite alors
qu'on était un peu ressenti délaissé
dans cette crise en mars 2 2020 donc
j'en profite pour vous remercier devant
mes collègues ici et et euh et et vous
dire toute notre gratitude parce que la
l'affaire a été gérée de mê maître et je
remercie la personne qui m'a donné vos
coordonnées alors mes mes questions mes
questions ont déjà été évoquées je
voulais on a parlé de distributeur et de
et et de répartition je voulais attirer
votre attention sur le fait que les
zones frontalières euh comme lamosel et
d'autres départements qui sont
frontaliers souffrent malgré certaines
négations de distribution en dehors des
frontières où les prix sont plus chers
donc je voulais attirer votre attention
sur ce point de 2ème question très
rapide aussi est-ce que vous avez vous
êtes saisi quand il y a une
réinternalisation de certains produits
et si c'est le cas est-ce que vous
sentez une une évolution favorable pour
augmenter cette reproduction sur site
enfin en France de certains produits et
la troisième qui est un peu plus
délicate me
semble-t-il vous l'avez évoqué c'est les
maladies rares voire très rares où vous
donnez l'autorisation sur le marché et
le prix en fonction du SMR or il est il
est difficile il est difficile et vous
le savez de faire des études cliniques
assez assez importantes dans ce cas-là
et ça ne risque pas d'aggraver certains
certaines pénuries pour certains
médicaments noovateurs qui qui ne seront
pas sur le marché français voilà
rapidement monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour terminer
Olivier merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Directrice beaucoup de
questions ont été posées donc d'abord
une une observation moi je n'arrive pas
à m'y faire he sur cette histoire de
pénurie de
paracétamol pédiatrique avec les moyens
que notre pays concentre ou
consacre à la santé je m'interroge donc
malgré tout tout sur la question de la
pertinence de notre organisation sa
réactivité voilà c'est c'est une c'est
une observation ma deuxème question ma
question plutôt ma deuxième observation
et deuxème question concerne aussi les
les innovations thérapeutique et
notamment les autorisations d'accès
précoce là aussi est-ce que vous pensez
que notre organisation notre système
d'organisation est pertinent et trouve
le juste équilibre entre la nécessaire
réactivité et souplesse et
l'indispensable responsabilité je vous
remercie madame lrice je vous propose 12
minutes pour répondre à toutes toutes
ces questions oui ou très bien merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur pour ce défi euh je vais
essayer d'être d'être
percutante sur sur le sujet en effet des
des des des pénuries sur le désolé je
n'arrivais plus à me relire euh sur le
sujet de la cartographie voilà c'est ça
j'aris plus complètement àer la
cartographie en effet des risques donc
oui nous sommes impliqués il y a un
travail euh étroit entre la NSM et la
Direction Générale des Entreprises euh
donc pour en effet cartographier euh
évidemment les vulnérabilité lorsque
l'on a qu'un seul site de production ou
ou qu'un seul façonnier euh je je vous
rappelez peut-être avant covid la pénuri
que nous avions eu sur les corticoïdes
avec un grand nombre de spécialités de
générique en eff de corticoïdes mais en
fait derrière il y a un seul façonnier
et donc il y avait des difficultés sur
voilà oui il y en a encore je suis assez
d'accord avec un seul voilà plutôt de la
distribution cette fois-ci pas voilà et
donc c'est là toute la difficulté mais
en effet il y a un seul façonnier donc
il y avait eu un et donc typiquement ce
sont en effet ces vulnérabilités donc
une collaboration étroite entre la NSM
et la direction générale des entreprises
pour mettre en évidence en effet ces
points de vulnérabilité et voir les
mesures possiblement de relocalisation
en effet au niveau national et je
l'avais déjà indiqué la maille
européenne aussi est probablement une
une bonne façon une bonne façon de faire
la charte des la charte d'engagement en
effet des acteurs de la chaîne je l'ai
dit c'est un appel et c'est un appel
fort évidemment du ministre à la
responsabilisation de de
chacun il y a encore enfin il y ailà je
je réunis dans le cadre de de la
gouvernance du plan hivernal l'ensemble
des acteurs de la chaîne tous les 15
jours et avec les professionnels de
santé les patients tous les mois il y a
une réunion qui va se tenir là euh pour
essayer de voir enfin que tout le monde
en effet œuvre dans le même sens à ce
stade avant l'application Réal du PLFSS
et de l'article 33 je ne peux qu'appeler
à la responsabilisation et à la
réorientation en effet des flux vers les
grossistes répartiteur avec l'article 33
j'aurai une base juridique législative
pour l'imposer ce que je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui j'ai adressé déjà des
courriers et notamment en octobre donc
voilà c'est la limite aussi des quand
quand on na pas de base législative hein
des recommandations en demandant en
effet aux industriels de réorienter
l'ensemble des enfin les flux de manière
revenir à du 820 comme cela existait
avant il semble que les effets soient un
petit peu longs à être à être visible
donc j'espère en effet extrêmement
fortement et fermement qu'il il va bien
y avoir en effet cette cette voilà
réallocation et notamment sur le sujet
des stocks de sécurité parce que c'est
c'est c'est aussi en effet des messages
qui sont malheureusement passé
évidemment dans une situation de tension
comme on a aujourd'hui je on n'impose
pas que il y ait 2 mois de stock de
sécurité et qu'on y touche pas alors que
les patients n'ont pas accès au
traitement bien évidemment ce sont ce
serait une hérésie enfin je désolé
d'être un petit peu trivial mais voilà
mais c'est évidemment une hérésie et
donc j'ai en effet indiqué très
clairement et y compris dès le mois de
mai 2023 en disant évidemment les stocks
de sécurité quand on est en situation de
tension il faut qu'il soit dans le
circuit et évidemment il n'y aura enfin
je on n'applique pas de sanctions
financière enfin c'est évident le le
l'objectif c'est avant tout que le
patient et son traitement donc voilà il
faut que ça soit répété répété et que ce
soit mis en pratique euh sur le sujet de
l'homéopathie voilà le déremboursement
vous le savez est sous lesgit de la
Haute Autorité de Santé ce n'est pas du
tout pour me défausser euh voilà mais
mais en effet le c'est typiquement le
sujet du bon usage très clairement euh
c'est aussi le fait de typiquement là
sur notamment sur le sujet utilisation
d'antibiotiques sur des pathologies
virales ça n'a pas lieu d'être c'est le
sujet de la l'utilisation de rien en
fait de rien c'est-à-dire qu'on on n pas
obligé de remplacer pas mais c'est
compliqué c'est tout un accompagnement
une éducation une pédagogie et c'est ça
qui est compliqué de tout tout le
travail en effet au quotidien des
médecins et des pharmaciens en effet
dans l'échange et faire comprendre aux
patients aussi en effet que voilà on n
pas forcément évidemment besoin d'
médicament sur
le j'avoue que je n'ai pas de compétence
en partie vétérinaire donc je ne
pourrais pas je ne pourrais pas
dire sur le sujet de
l'ES c'est ça vous aviez posé la
question sur le sujet de l'agence
innovation en santé non pardon Laurence
je crois que c'est sur 18 mois oui sur
le DM ah pardon DM et j'avais aussi le
sujet de la
matigilance oui donc sur sur la
matériovigilance en effet avec
évidemment des remontées on a le la
structuration d'un résseau aussi comme
les CRPV donc qui se monte en effet sur
la matériovigilance avec évidemment des
champs beaucoup plus larges les
dispositifs médicaux ce sont des
centaines de de milliers de dispositifs
médicaux mais réellement en eff fait une
mobilisation au niveau régional donc ça
monte ça monte en puissance évidemment
l'utilisation des trodes ça c'est un
point évidemment majeur ce qui est
permis aussi la dans le cadre avec la
mobilisation par les pharmaciens et en
effet on voilà j'ai j'ai une j'ai une
grande voilà une une grande confiance en
effet dans la coordination entre
médecins et pharmaciens et la
réalisation des trodes des trodes par
les par les pharmaciens et sur le sujet
des vasau constructeurs oui le sujet des
naso qui sont sur prescription médical
aujourd'hui mais avec des volumes
importants comme les vasau constructeur
euro avec des mesures nécessaires aussi
aussi à prendre concernant la maladie
d'Alzheimer à nouveau
le sujet du déremboursement n'est pas un
sujet sous l'égide de de la NSM sur le
sujet des anticorps monoclonaux
évidemment du point de vue de la NSM la
seule chose que nous regardons c'est le
bénéfice risque en effet et et c'est
évidemment un point un point important
et ensuite donc c'est une évaluation qui
est faite au niveau centralisé parce que
ce sont des médicaments dit innovants
donc ils sont uniquement biotechnologie
donc avec la mobilisation de la France
très de manière très forte mais au
niveau europ et donc avec une mise une
mise ensuite sur la prise en charge
voilà voilà oui oui tout à
fait et sur le sujet juste parce que
vous revenez sur le sujet des troubles
menstruels la la mobilisation de
l'agence les communications était avant
en effet notamment le rapport de l'OPEX
la modification j'en suis qu ouis en
terme de calendrier la modification des
RCP et des notices a été en effet après
pour une raison en effet simple puisque
ce c'est sous l'égide de l'Agence EUR
euréne du médicament ce sont des vaccins
en effet c'est la Commission européenne
en effet qui ensuite modifie le RCP et
la notice et donc nous ne sommes pas
maîtres évidemment pleinement des des
calendriers mais on peut toujours
s'améliorer en terme en terme de
rapidité euh sujet des euh des pénuries
en effet sur la qualité inégale en effet
des PGP euh donc avec en effet notamment
à la fois euh des euh en effet sur la
fin de l'année 2023 et 2024 des
contrôles renforcés sur les PGP donc on
a déjà en effet mis en place un comment
on appelle ça un
oh excusez-moi un un cahier des charges
renforcé en effet pour partager avec
l'ensemble des industriels pour remplir
en effet les PGP et nous allons
mobiliser mes équipes en effet vont
mobiliser des contrôles renforcés sur
sur les PGP et également aussi sur les
stocks de sécurité les 7 ETP que nous
avons eu dans notre dotation
supplémentaire pourront évidemment on a
j'ai évidemment un sujet de priorisation
mais c'est un point majeur pourront être
utilement mobilisés en effet sur le
sujet de l'anticipation et de la qualité
des PGP et également sur le sujet des
stocks de sécurité la distribution aller
plus loin j'en ai parlé l'article 33 me
permettra d'avoir une asscise
législative imposant en effet c'est
réorientation de de flux euh sur le
sujet en effet des zones frontalières et
sur la la distribution possiblement
d'exportation parallèle nous faisons des
contrôles des inspections en effet pour
vérifier en fait quand on a une
déclaration de tension ou de rupture et
que nous mettons ce qu'on appelle une
fiche rupture de stock sur notre site
automatiquement la mise en ligne de
cette fiche interdit toute exportation
parallèle au grossisse répartiteur et
donc nous mobilisons des contrôles alors
je pas en flux continu parce que je n'
ai pas les moyens mais nous mobilisons
des campagnes en effet pour vérifier si
il y a évidemment des écarts et s'il y a
des écarts dans ces cas-là il y a il y a
des sanctions euh la relocalisation de
la production en effet c'est un point
qui est évidemment important je disais
le maillage la maille européenne est
aussi évidemment à prendre en compte et
sur le sujet des maladies rares à
nouveau et je ne veux pas du tout
remettre sur une autre institution mais
le sujet SMR et asmr est sous lesgidees
de la voilà de la Haute Autorité de
Santé donc pas de la NSM pour autant
nous sommes très attachés est très très
très appliqué sur le sujet de l'accès
pour les maladies rares à la fois les
accès précoces mais aussi ce que l'on
appelle les cadres de prescription
compassionnel on le sait on a un certain
nombre de molécules qui sont développées
dans une indication qui pour des
maladies rares ne vont pas forcément
être développé par l'industriel dans une
autre indication et l'agence est en
capacité après analyse de la littérature
et donc on travaille avec les filières
maladies rares de pouvoir octroyer un
cadre de prescription compassionnel qui
permet aux patients d'accéder à ces
molécules et donc nous travaillons et
nous allons renforcer en effet ces
échanges et cette collaboration
évidemment sur base de d'une présomption
de bénéfice risque mais pour permettre
aux patients atteints de maladies rares
voir de maladies très RAR de pouvoir
avoir accès de pouvoir avoir accès en
effet au traitement et donc avec le
sujet en effet d'un juste équilibre
entre sur les accès précoces en effet la
présomption de bénéfice risque et donc
le voilà le le la part je dirais
d'incertitude qui existe mais qui est
considéré comme suffisamment acceptable
eu égard au bénéfices pour les patients
et qui ne peuvent pas attendre d'avoir à
disposition ces
traitements merci beaucoup Madame la
Directrice pour cet exercice un peu
compliqué voilà de réponse circoncise
mais vous êtes voilà c'est très bien et
bien nous allons passer très rapidement